an average director given a great
screenplay you might be in trouble
how do you judge a movie what's your
rating system it is
really when i look at a film and i'm
watching i'm evaluating film and i'm
determining
is it accomplishing what it's setting
out to accomplish so what is the mission
of the film what what is the filmmaker
trying to do with this film you know
when you watch a film like hereditary
what ari aster is trying to do with that
film is much different
than what uh kaczynski's doing with with
top gun maverick they're they're but but
yet
so you're judging them in ultimately
what were they trying to do with the
story okay and did they deliver it
in the way that in the best possible way
that that they were
capable of doing and i think that it's
it's one of those things when you you
just
you have to you obviously have to see a
lot of films to to know what what is
what is
of a good quality of an excellent
quality and then an absolutely you know
otherworldly stratospheric quality you
need to see plenty of films to get to
that point but but those are rare
but i think that you're ultimately just
trying to figure out
what
is the director trying to do here and
did they do it with maximum impact
and top gun maverick is stratospheric
absolutely yeah i mean i mean just
because of because it delivers
what it was intending to do and does it
above even that level so you're
expecting the sequel that's kind of just
there right it's it's it's a sequel we
see so many sequels that are just kind
of unnecessary right they make it and
it's just a money grab and there's no
real uh emotional value to it and i
think that this film what people are
resonating why it's doing the the
business it's doing it's going to
continue to do over the next several
weeks months and years is that it gives
you all of those pieces that you're
looking for and and that is rare that
it's able to do that especially in the
sequel it's very difficult to do um but
but when you watch a film i think
ultimately for me when i when i'm out
evaluating a film and i'm watching it
um you never want to dislike a film ever
you want to like a film i i don't drive
across town to century city to watch to
beverly hills 2 to the fox lot to santa
monica you don't drive all those places
in rush hour traffic to go watch a film
and go this is terrible you don't want
to do that you want to like everything i
think a lot of people think that we you
go in and say ah no they they wanted to
hate this film just all crimes the
future i wanted to like it i love
cronenberg but this is a film that feels
flat this is a film that is going to be
for extremely narrow uh
audience it's just it's not and it it's
just a doll film and i think that i
wanted to like it but but you don't ever
go in wanting to dislike a film it just
happens
right
so
you try to remain as detached as
possible and i think one thing that's
very important when you when you're
watching a film
if you love a director let's say that
i'm going to see
the next safety brother films and i mean
good time is one of my favorite films of
the past decade easy i mean that is just
absolutely gangbusters everything about
that film is just
uh but if i see the next safety brothers
film i'm gonna try to get all that out
of my head and i'm gonna say what are we
doing here um
it's not
obviously entirely possible to get rid
of all of the the goodwill that you had
from before but you've got to try to go
in there as much as possible to blank
slate so that you don't become like oh
this is the safety brothers so that
means that i'm going to have to love
this or it's going to be great doesn't
mean that we see plenty of directors
that have maybe their best film is their
first film right and they go down then
we have directors who go up there we
have some of the plateau whatever that
is
every film has to be evaluated on its
own
not
as part of a legacy of a director or an
actor or a studio or a distributor or
any of these things you have to just go
in there and be as unbiased as possible
and i think for some for some people
it's it's difficult i think it is i
think it's uh
that you you it's hard to fight that i
want to like this film um or you know i
i know this is going to be good or i
know this can be bad there's some people
that go in like that you have to be as
down the middle as possible when you go
to see these films and i think that
ultimately
the people that resonate with you
they they listen to you or they read
your reviews or they listen to your
words about any given film
they know that you
are
a fair critic and you're not
biased you are not trying to uh impart
your own you're trying to just judge
this film on its own individual merits
period right regardless of who the
director is regardless of the actors
involved the studio it's all about just
that singular film and what is on the
screen
and how much do you think the original
actors being in the sequel contributes
to the public loving the film
you have to i mean
other than kelly mcgillis right who's
not in this you i think it's it's
important to bring that you have to have
obviously those original characters you
don't want to recast all those or not
bring some of them back i mean you in
top maverick you brought almost
everybody back right you have crews
kilmer comes back sorry if that's a if
that's a spoiler uh it's out there i
think everyone knows that by now uh
miles teller does a great job as goose's
uh son obviously anthony edwards does
not come back
but but when you look at that that film
it's it's the characters are there that
you know so you already go in there with
familiarity which is not uh something to
be taken lightly so i think that the
director had again i think that
kaczynski when you look at that he has
an absolute uh very much of a reverence
for the predecessor for top gun and um
that may not have been the case for for
everybody who took that project on
okay blade runner oh
old versus new oh
blade runner original oh blade runner
yeah no blade runner 82
right 82 yeah i think so no blade runner
is it's not even a comparison people say
blade runner 2049 or play oh my god no
blade runner and and
you gotta i mean going back that that
film has has stood the test of time i
mean when you watched blade runner today
in its many
uh forms right there's so many different
versions of that film from the narration
to the no narration to to so many but
whatever version you're watching uh what
scott did with that film was so far
ahead of its time and the fact that it
still looks like something that we could
see on the screen today and not be like
well this looks really dated right the
effects the vangelis score
um obviously harrison ford
and you you look at that film and it's a
film that really
expands your mind especially as a young
kid watching that film it that's a
that's absolutely one of the seminal
films for me when i talk about films
that really
created my cinematic soul it's it's
blade runner and then when i sat and
watched blade runner 2049
as much as i appreciate denis and i
think that he is one of our best
directors i think that he in that film
almost every scene in 2049
runs too long uh it goes past its
natural expiration date right so you
have this natural point where the it
feels like the the scenes that's it
let's go to the next scene and we are
still there for a minute or two
afterwards i think that's the flaw of
2049 is there's a there's a lot to like
in that film but
usually my role ruled is this whenever i
look at a film it's almost always this
right less is more
almost always
and i think 2049 at less is better than
2049 at moore which is what we got which
is interesting because when you watch
dune when i sat through dune i was
expecting to see the exact same issues i
saw in 2049 um because i i figured he he
didn't learn he's gonna you know he's
gonna do the same thing he did with with
blade runner 2049 and that's not the
case dune
really the pacing of dune is is
something that i was surprised at i was
expecting that film again to each scene
go well past where the natural edit
point should be and it lingers on that
film doesn't somehow it managed to and
that's why dune was my favorite film of
of last year i mean it wasn't even a
contest uh dude the filmmaking
to the story i don't care you know the
funny people say oh it's a part one we
can't we can't give it best picture
because it's part one why what are the
rules who says that right who says that
we have to do return of the king and
wait for that i mean if you you talk
about that your
lord of the rings too is very clearly
the best of the those three films i mean
i think there's no contest to that but
yet it didn't win but we have return of
the king winning so
you know who's to know if dune 2 is
going to be better than dune 1 but this
whole mindset if we can't give it best
picture we can't say it was the best
film
of the year because it's only the first
part it wasn't a full film why why i
don't am i missing a rule
um so i think that mindset of that's
another thing that i think we have a
major problem with is is with awards for
sure is
we can't do this because this film
doesn't fit into the parameters of what
an awards film is right it's it's not a
horror film we can't have a horror film
be a best picture like really why can't
we why can't we have
hereditary as a best picture i mean
talk about a film that knocks you on
your ass and granted makes you feel like
hell but that's the point you know when
i talked to ari astor it was at the a24
party um at christmas and i saw ariester
and i said i'm gonna know when i first
came out on redditor i did not like your
film and then i thought i said
no actually i love it because you made
me feel
like hell
like i just been through
uh true hell and and that's the that's
the power of hereditary and that is
absolutely
certainly one of the best horror films
of all time in my estimation
but why can't that be a best picture why
can't i mean just because it makes you
feel like absolute crap doesn't mean it
can't be a best picture but i mean we
all know that that's not the world we
live in we live in this world of this
has to be this upper kind of thing i
mean again go back to coda uh a true
upper of a film right absolutely
and
but but i don't i think we have this
problem where we have to say this film
is this we have to it can only work in
this arena x is a great example same
thing from this year listen if you ask
me the two best films i've seen this
year it is x and top gun maverick for
very different reasons but both because
they're extremely well directed
so really for me it starts at direction
the number one thing for a film
is direction there's not even a question
you can give an average screenplay to
an a stud of a director a star absolute
you know top shelf director is gonna
take
an average screenplay and make a decent
film conversely an average director
given a great screenplay you might be in
trouble
right because the choices are different
um not everybody's gonna make the same
film i mean you could watch so many
different versions of any given film
based on who the director is i think
it's a very singular individual skill
and the vision the artistic vision of a
director is the number one thing for a
film and so if the direction is strong
the likelihood of me liking it is going
to be very high
do you know usually within a minute
within an opening
no
no no
you have a fee you can know it's going
to go down but i don't know if you know
if you can go up so if it's really like
the beginning and just like some some of
the choices are really like wow that's
that's something then you start to go
okay we're in trouble but i think that
uh unless i mean even top gun maverick i
mean the beginning i absolutely love i
think it's a perfect choice for that
film but i didn't at that point say okay
that means that the whole rest of the
film's gonna be good i think that's the
danger too you have to constantly when
you're watching a film you have to
constantly be on this balance board of
trying to say is what i'm watching
working or not and that can change
throughout the film you could start low
and end up high i mean i go back to a
film looper um
ryan johnson's film i mean that is a
film that i was down on down on i was up
then i was down and then the choice at
the end was put me back up so that his
choice of what what the characters do
makes looper a film that i recommend but
i was up and down on that like a roller
coaster so i think that's the key you're
constantly evaluating it it's almost
like you literally have things strapped
right to your in your you can almost
judge those levels of where you are on
what you're watching you have to be that
way throughout the whole thing because
it could change you could love a film
all the way up until the end or dislike
it until like i said looper up um so you
know you hopefully are going to start
pretty high and stay and ride up right
um it's rare that you see something that
starts really low and then you end up
really high so
right so so i guess if you see something
that's not good yeah that might be but
if it's rare i mean most films don't
come out of the gate and like oh my god
this is terrible even fire starter i
just i just
fire starter but get the weird thing
about fire starter the remake
is that the first
25 minutes are decent you watch this
filming like i like some of these
choices i like the the title sequence is
really strong but that's a film that
starts here and goes down across the
board so those are those are rare too